[Music]
zach ertz
dallas goddard a couple of tight ends in
philadelphia goddard the guy who is on
the way up recognizing that hurts is
about to get paid said dallas goddard
yesterday kittle and kelsey signing
those contracts really helped out the
tight end market so that's always
amazing thanks to those guys but zach
deserves a contract here he's been here
been a top three tight end in the league
personally i believe he's the best in
the league for the last bunch of years
so he definitely deserves whatever he's
about to get that's dallas goddard a guy
who's going to be on deck for a contract
of his own at some point either with the
eagles or somewhere else chris
that that's the reality the more that
they pay earth's the harder it will be
to pay goddard yeah so if they give arts
a gigantic contract if you look at how
the cap dollars work that could be the
ticket that results in goddard being out
of town so he needs to be careful what
he wishes for if he wants to stay with
the eagles yeah no no doubt about it i
mean it's a good problem to have
certainly but yeah you're right i mean
if they box themselves into whoa we've
paid too much money for zach ertz
you know you you miss the opportunity to
sign up another guy who's got a long
shelf life still to go in the nfl and
could be your future you know zac er it
says his career starts to unwind here
you know i mean zach gertz is he's
starting to he's plateaued i think he's
starting to you know at the plateau
we're going to start to hit the decline
here soon too to where uh yeah they got
to be careful with the contract in my
opinion
all right so in honor of the earth's
contract talks and in recognition the
fact that travis kelsey and george
kittle got theirs recently and exempting
them from this exercise this is the
travis kelsey george kittle memorial
draft the best tight ends in the nfl
chris you have a question for me
oh i got the question i was not ready
for that oh no didn't i ask you the
question yesterday am i asking chris let
me ask chris all right here we go
nfl history has caught 1 000 receiving
yards who is it
one rookie tight end time it's about a
thousand receiving
hope if you watch my podcast you would
know cause we talked about it but you
know i i i don't watch your pie i watch
your afternoon podcast as much as you
watch my afternoon podcast i'm just
gonna throw a dart and say kellen
winslow the original kellen winslow oh
sorry sorry ghost rider no it's mike
ditka it is right and that amazing
thousand receiving yards for a tight end
in 1961
that's amazing i would have never got
you could have given me 10 guesses and i
wouldn't have come up with mike ditka
all right you get the first pick okay
first pick it's actually not the easiest
first pick in the world here um
i think though honestly
i'm going to go with austin hooper as my
first pick okay i'm gonna go there yeah
i i like well-rounded tight ends and
austin hooper you know of course really
good in the past game uh but an awesome
run blocker too
you know to where you can't just peg him
to one thing so we saw cleveland paid
you know pretty good money for him i
don't think atlanta wanted to lose him
because atlanta made a trade to get
another good tight end and hayden hurst
after that but uh i think austin hooper
is the guy that i'm gonna go with here
this is a tough one because it's a very
close group here but uh well-rounded
tight end and really has no weakness to
his game
it's gonna be tough though to get the
production out of who maybe with otto
beckham jr jarvis landry nick chubb and
kareem hunt but you know so he may not
show it this year and i don't know how
much my pick is going to show it during
the regular season but he's going to
show it in the postseason if they keep
him healthy and until he is dethroned
the king of all tight ends continues to
be
rob gronkowski gone for a year
not forgotten i'm astounded you didn't
take him no he's the best titan i he'd
have possibly been my first pick even if
kitto and kelsey were still in play yeah
it's fine i don't care if i know what
gronk's going to do with the season on
the line and we've we've got other guys
that we know they can perform we know
kelsey and kittle can perform at a high
level and long term i'd want both of
them on my team over gronk but for this
year give me gronk because i know when
it's time to make the big catch from tom
brady with the season riding on it he's
going to do it well all right all right
i'm in that's iffy i mean he hasn't
played football in a year
you know we'll see about his production
too as we've heard i mean you know they
got other tight ends down there too so
i'm with you he's gonna have definitely
a niche in the red zone and i'm sure
he's gonna be in there in a lot of big
moments there's no doubt about that um
all right next guy man
you left zach ertz on the board here so
i gotta go with zach ertz i'm gonna go
with him i mean again it's a passing
league the guy has a niche in the
passing game yeah do i wish he was a
better run blocker certainly you know
he's not a very effective that way but
in the past game you know similar to a
travis kelsey where he's very slick he's
a really good route runner is he gonna
break like big plays after the catch and
break tackles no not necessarily but
he's gonna break through some arm
tackles and make a guy miss to get an
extra four or five yards and do all that
too let alone he has phenomenal hand so
you're gonna leave zach hurts out there
i'm gonna take it
yeah look uh i i did leave him out there
because again i'd still rather have
gronk when the season is on the line and
he's still right hopefully they make the
playoffs tampa because if they don't
that would be a wasted pick
with seven spots in the nfc they'll make
the playoffs all right i'm gonna go
hunter henry franchise tagged by the
chargers especially with the mike
williams news we discussed earlier he's
got a shoulder injury that's keeping him
out for a while if he's not out there
it's more opportunities for henry and
you know henry's had that career that's
a little bit of a mixed bag he had 652
receiving yards last year and five
touchdowns but you know this is a guy
who i think uh could have a very
productive season especially if they get
justin herbert out there on the field
but even with tyrod taylor we've said
this about taylor over and over again
he's been pretty good in his career and
he's never had the weapons like the ones
he's going to have this year right and
henry a big part of that all right
you're up next yeah he's super talented
henry definitely i mean just stay
healthy i mean he can become a big time
target um
i can't believe this that you know this
guy's gonna be here for this third pick
this this really might be the guy who i
this was really my first pick i just
didn't think you'd take him darren
waller the oakland raiders you know i'm
not gonna lie i think right now and i've
said this on my podcast it would go
kittle one kelsey two darren waller
three and tight ends in football right
now hey 90 receptions had 1100 yards
receiving and he's an awesome blocker
too i know you and i have discussed on
the show too like the raiders were
really smart and getting out in front of
you know his contract they did something
we talk about all the time let's not
wait for the guy to explode and then try
to sign him let's like have a little
vision to go wait this guy's really damn
good he's gonna explode let's sign him
up now for nine million dollars a year i
mean they gotta steal with that darren
waller is awesome he is the type of
tight end that you can formulate a game
plan around and uh i can't believe i'm
getting there's more good tight ends
than football than you realize once you
start to go down the this draft yeah and
and this last one for me is going to be
very difficult you know i know rudolph
is a guy that i considered he he he
doesn't have the production that he used
to he had the big catch though in the
playoff game to extend the season i'm
going to go jared cook of the saints
good for you
jared cook especially now with michael
thomas and emmanuel sanders he may find
more opportunities this year than he's
than he's had he still had 705 receiving
yards last year for the saints in 14
games and uh we've seen him deliver some
big catches in big moments and uh i i
think i think he's a guy who could could
have a big impact on new orleans offense
this year chris yeah no no he's an
awesome football player you know i was a
teammate of his with the tennessee
titans he's a huge man he's got great
body control and as we've seen
you know he's kind of special where he
can catch a ball 10 yards over the
middle and split a defense and run for a
70 yard touchdown i mean he really can
so that's a special skill set and i
think year two and that sean payton
offense you're gonna see that kind of
take off too man i mean we didn't even
he's he's he's me he's made big catches
he had that catch from aaron rodgers in
the playoff game a couple years ago
right but he's always seemed to overplay
his hand when it's time to negotiate a
new contract and he never really stays
in one place no you're right yeah
it seems very fair to say that i mean
but man we didn't know a fan tj
hawkinson who i expect to be in the
convo for best tight ends in football
how about our guy in baltimore we didn't
get to mark andrews you know i didn't
know if you were going to take gronk and
i think that's the guy who got left off
the list because you took grunk but i
won the draft today good try though good
work mike
okay we'll see when gronk has his hands
on the super bowl trophy we'll bring
this tape back
if either of us remember it which
probably will not happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports